1984 has been a tough year our sales are
down our growth is down sunny I brush
you in here to grow the basketball
business
people don't know what the hell a Nike
is what's a Converse NBA All-Star shoes
there's nothing cool about Nike
you would have to have a pretty
compelling pitch I could tell them the
one thing the other companies can't
compete with
our basketball Division is terrible I do
not love it
this is where you come up with a
brilliant idea that no one else can see
let's hear it
I got it I found him who's that Jesus
can't afford it I'm willing to bet my
career on one guy
my name is Sonny Vaccaro I'm with Nike
do you typically make it a habit of
showing up at people's front doors
unannounced I don't like to take no for
an answer oh man here we go you asked me
what I do here this is what I do I find
you players and I feel it this time okay
it's risky when you were selling
sneakers out of the back here Plymouth
that was risky don't change that now for
a rookie yes who's never set foot on an
NBA court if that's the literal
definition of rookie yeah
what's the plan we build a shoe line
around just him
I need the greatest basketball shoe
that's ever been made who's the player
Michael Jordan
[Music]
you have our attention
I believe in his son I believe he's the
future and his story is going to make us
want to fly but a shoe is just a shoe
until my son steps into them
all right
you got a name for it
Air Jordan
I don't know
seriously no maybe it'll grow on me
[Music]